if I taste my meal and it's awful I can
at least serve cereal so amber in the
Blanco and I'm a producer for Ben tasty
and tasty people are kind of like
embracing the random things like my
name's Spencer Althouse
I don't have much experience as a cook I
do watch a lot of Food Network though as
much as I like cooking I don't venture
out because I am too scared to try
something make it and then have it not
taste good and then I'm like okay well I
just ruin this whole meal I'm very
nervous but I'm also super competitive
so I hope that my years of watching
different network have served me well it
has a huge power it as far as I know you
could have actually learn how to cook
watch any I have no idea what's inside
this box of surprises thirty dollars
this is New York yeah we get that we can
get like two Brussels sprouts for $30
and that's about it if someone who is
very single and doesn't go on many dates
I'm not very excited I've been married
for a long time I've never done like a
first date kind of thing oh man it's
gonna be a disaster
I'm like trying to create like four
different recipes inside my mind and
hope that one of them has like all the
ingredients that I have there and then
unscrewed it looks like it's more of a
deli than an actual place to buy food
maybe I can do something with some of
these stuff maybe I can bread something
with
I grabbed the fettuccine and I start
looking for like sauces and I was super
lucky to find tomato sauce and some
roasted peppers which is awesome because
those kind of do go together I have five
more minutes and I need to [ __ ] out of
here for those meatballs thank you so
much
this is going to be for an imaginary boy
they need protein and let's do something
with this okay this is the moment of
truth $29 guys precisely on point I
don't know you can do this but good luck
bye seriously I do wish you good luck
right before I walked into the bodega I
had to meal ideas in my mind one was
gonna be ramen and then the other one
was french toast and then as I got into
the bodega I realized that there was
more of an option for French toast
there's no bread in here do you have
like regular eggs can I do for them and
then do you have any regular bread as
well just like slices of white bread or
something
I've soft cereal and I want to dip the
french toast
in cereal afterwards but what kind of
cereal do I want I take the cocoa
pebbles and then I grab some Nutter
butters because I'm like okay I can
crunch these up and like maybe the
peanut butters part of it will taste
really good with the French toast and
like the chocolate from the cocoa
pebbles I was hoping they had like
cinnamon toast crunch that I could just
take the cinnamon is this the same thing
as proper lemon juice I'm an amateur for
a reason guys things Special K just in
case I need milk perfect
I'm especially nervous about this
because it's literally the first time
that I'm ever making french toast and I
don't know if that's a very smart move
to go into a cooking competition where
I'm cooking a meal that I have never
made before so hopefully I don't set
myself up for failure start sweating
right now okay
I'm so nervous I'm like I don't even
have to whisk this because I'm shaking
that's how nervous I am for french toast
you need to mix I just learned this
today you have to mix eggs and milk and
supposedly cinnamon butter them have
some in together and like whisk that up
to dip the bread in to like to make the
Cody for the French toast but then I
thought as a way to like elevate it it
would be cool to add like the cocoa
pebbles and the Nutter Butter like
crunched up he calls me he says you know
the cereal is not sticking to the French
toast and I'm like okay like let me you
let's sing it it's not sticking
you didn't mash the cereal it was just
like expecting like it to magically
stick to the French toast and it's just
that's when I realized oh my god ah you
want this to be smaller that's oh my god
she didn't help me out there I'll give
her that
[Music]
so he gives looking at my way then he
sees me pulling out like this crazy huge
meatballs and I guess the size did
scared him and he stars like yelling I
see I hate you I hate you so much
there's legal proper meal there like you
guys got 10 minutes and I'm ready to
search I've already like grabbing my
play and Spencer's on the other side
seeing that he has to redo it's french
toast because he burned three of them it
was just really fun to see him at the at
that moment like they're like drops of
sweat and he's looking Briah head the
cheese over top is just created so
perfectly that it's like falling like
snowflakes and I'm so jealous and I'm
mad that I didn't have confectionary
sugar to like put on top of my french
toast because that would be like equal
to what her Parmesan cheese is to her
plate hers looks really good and I'm mad
that I had to go up against that he
knows he's sham looks amazing oh my god
he's just being really humble but it's
only being acknowledged I wish it would
have thought to be honest but now I'm
just like oh well you didn't taste it
yet so you don't know it could have
sucks
[Music]
now go to the point right there cuz I
just spilled on my face yeah it's really
good it's really well-seasoned this is
definitely something that you would get
at like a nice Italian restaurant that
if someone super trying to impress
someone else we're on our first day and
then like if the girls eating it can be
very like sloppy looking you know I like
this man can taste the sweet in it
I mean people you breakfast for dinner
too so it could be like a breakfast
dinner you're trying to be a little
unexpected yes we're gonna go for pasta
pasta it's more intimate feeling and the
winner is definitely the French toast
they changed my life I might have to
take a plate with me right now
if you were like oh I'm gonna make
breakfast on my first date that kind of
implies that you want a lot from it and
I'm not sure how I feel about that so I
think I'm gonna go with the pasta is the
better choice looks like creative he
said of the simple process I'd probably
go with the french toast
I feel like it's safer than trying to
deal with like tomato sauce and garlic
press and that's just like a whole lot
of added nerves you're really this dough
so they just take them off
really good french toast on french toast
strawberries are a little soggy but easy
to eat the pastas cooked very well
the meat is actually pretty good and
seasoned pretty well I don't think any
guy would think that was like a few
mister buddies make the bread a little
bit soggy oh my god I don't know what to
say
I want to thank I'm a garden and my mom
for teaching me how to bake even though
I made french toast and didn't bake it
and I would like to thank Brenda for she
really did help me through this
I'm happy you won I should have never
helped them okay well I'll take this
home but we'll share it right now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]